in 2002 fbi and cia agents thought they
had nabbed a diabolical al qaeda
mastermind
abu zubaydah has never been charged with
a crime
he was imprisoned in the secret cia unit
called strawberry fields
as in forever
prior to 9 11 gi never captured or
detained anybody
they weren't prepared people started
looking for who was best to interrogate
and there weren't any psychologist james
mitchell was the only candidate
considered i just took it for granted
that they knew what they were doing
cia officers were certain he was holding
back because he wasn't telling them what
they wanted to hear
something more aggressive had to be done
the lawyer's philosophy is tell me what
you want to do boss and i'll make it
legal we asked him to draw what was done
to him abu zubaydah is put in isolation
everything that was happening was
mitchell's experiments nudity has been
approved sleep deprivation has been
approved noise has been approved the
same song again and again and again
spent 11 days in a coffin shaped box he
was on the water board
i mean this is crazy
the best evidence of what happened is
the video what was the reason why you
thought that it was important to have
the tapes destroyed
i needed to protect the people who were
there destroying evidence would
inevitably lead to accusations of a
color
it would make the cia look bad
it was an impossible story to tell so i
sued the cia to get materials unredacted
we saw constant manipulation by the cia
misleading bush misleading obama if my
boss tells me it's legal if the
president approved it i'm not going to
get into what some journalist thinks
about it
in america we have this thing called
innocent until proven guilty we were the
leaders of the effort against cruel and
unusual punishment after 9 11 that's out
the window the ends always justify the
means are we prepared to abandon our
principles
in order to defend them
you